[Music]
how could one of the largest and most
important companies in the world
collapse in just a few years what could
lead a diversified industrial company
with more than 100 years behind it to
the brink of bankruptcy what lessons can
we learn about business strategy from
the decline of general electric well
let's find out
[Applause]
[Music]
for decades general electric was the
great symbol of the united states
prolific and lucrative manufacturing
industry a giant that manufactured and
exported high value-added goods and
services all over the world from
aircraft engines and turbines for huge
hydroelectric power plants to small
household appliances and light bulbs its
activities also extended into banking
media and railroads the historic company
founded by thomas edison himself did
practically everything it had presence
in 130 countries and more than 300 000
employees
it was during the 80s and 90s when
general electric experienced its
greatest glory under the leadership of
its popular ceo jack welsh it became the
largest conglomerate in the world and
also reaped its greatest financial
successes we are talking about a company
that since the end of world war ii
maintained its position among the
largest and most valuable companies in
the world in fact in 2001 and for
several years during the 1990s this
boston-based company occupied first
place in the global rankings exactly the
same place that apple occupies today
general electric had a market
capitalization of some 600 billion
dollars in august of 2000
today however things are completely
different the arrival of the new century
this giant began a torturous path that
put it on the ropes
for the approximately 600 billion
dollars at which it was valued at its
peak at the beginning of the century
today its market cap has fallen to a
little above 100 billion dollars we are
talking about an 80 destruction of value
over the last 20 years so the question
is how can we explain such a cataclysm
how could the largest north american
company collapse in such a way is it not
a highly diversified group well let's
find out
[Applause]
[Music]
troubled waters
in the late 1990s technology companies
began to become the stars of the market
at that time to regain momentum jack
welsh made a decision that would
ultimately be the beginning of the end
the entry into the banking business
according to the plans of the then
reputed ceo of general electric the
financial business would allow them not
only to further diversify their
activities and obtain juicy profits but
also to finance their own activities at
very advantageous conditions so no
sooner that was said than it was done in
practice they created their own bank
general electric capital
to achieve this welsh transformed what
had been until then a division focused
on financing customers purchases into a
financial platform that did everything
from insurance subprime mortgages and
consumer loans under welsh's successor
jeff emelet during the first years of
the 21st century this financial division
positioned itself as one of the largest
banks in the whole of the united states
at that time no one could have suspected
the financial earthquake that would
occur in 2008. in fact shortly before
the crisis general electric capital made
one of its last major acquisitions wmc
mortgage a subprime mortgage lender a
company that as you can imagine suffered
a lot from the bursting of the housing
bubble and the financial tsunami that
followed it came close to taking the
whole group down with it
and so in 2008 general electric share
price collapsed and the hole created by
the financial division was so great that
if it had not been for the rescue of the
federal government and warren buffett
the group might not have survived that's
right on the first of october 2008
warren buffett announced that he would
cover three billion dollars of an urgent
12 billion dollar increase that general
electric had to raise to try and get
some liquidity
[Music]
because in 2008 the group's net debt
exceeded
500 billion dollars general electric
alone a century-old industrial company
had more debt than most governments in
the world
years of cash field growth and rampant
banking had turned it into a huge
mountain of debt of course that was not
the end of the nightmare it took general
electric six long years to completely
liquidity its troubled financial
businesses in addition to the enormous
debt incurred profitability problems
began to emerge in many of its divisions
due to a lack of strategic focus under
investment in key projects and a lack of
agility in adapting to market changes
all of this forced it to auction off
many of its business areas to the
highest bidder such as the media and
plastic divisions among many other
sectors so look for example at how its
pre-tax profit has evolved even before
excluding extraordinary costs and losses
[Music]
finally in 2017 jeff emelet was forced
to step down he pressed a baton to john
flannery a 30-year veteran at the
company but he could do little more than
cut the dividends and continue to
auction off units including two of the
company's historic divisions the light
bulb and the railroad businesses however
at the beginning of 2018 after a
disastrous year in which general
electric posted the losses of more than
six billion dollars due to the
deterioration of its insurance division
and suspicions of accounting
irregularities there was another
leadership change in october 2018 barely
a year after being appointed to the
position john flannery passed the reigns
to larry kulp the current ceo and the
architect of a new strategy that
represents a new turning point in the
world of corporate strategies this is an
example of how things have changed in
recent years from pursuing the creation
of industrial giants larry kulp's
strategy is to divide the company
according to its activities something
like we're better off alone separate and
focused on each one's own activity and
together in a large conglomerate it's a
move from integration to specialization
and that that is exactly what they are
doing now check this out
the big turnaround
after taking the helm larry kulp
implemented a crash plan he effectively
abolished dividend payments sold off
large parts of the business in order to
reduce the enormous accumulated debt
introduced major operational changes
substantially reduced the conglomerate
structure and sold off most of the
financial arm still in the group's hands
all with the aim of stabilizing the
group and recovering cash generation but
that was only the beginning
after a long restructuring period and
many lurches after being on the verge of
bankruptcy in 2008 general electric has
finally made a decision to separate the
emblematic company founded by edison
into three different companies
specifically according to the
established plan general electric will
spin off its healthcare business in
early 2023 and the energy business in
2024 with the remaining company becoming
ge aviation a company specializing in
jet engines
[Music]
in this way the group's three major
areas of activity can be managed in
completely different ways they are
following a strategy of specialization
as the key to competitiveness this marks
the end of the decades long history that
made this company the most iconic
industrial giant in the united states in
this decision by the way the pressure
exerted by the activist fund tree and
fund management led by investor nets and
pelts played a major role
[Music]
be that as it may the point is that the
decision made by the boston team is a
sign of how important specialization is
size is not synonymous with
profitability especially when that size
is made of a very diverse activities in
such cases bureaucracy and a lack of
specialization can come at significant
cost to shareholders general electric's
decision was not exceptional on the
contrary this move follows what we can
already define as a trend in the world
of corporate management check this out
the end of the big conglomerates
general electric's termination of its
130-year history as an industrial
conglomerate was very well publicized at
the end of the year but it was far from
being the only player to follow the
divide and conquer motto in recent times
many companies are betting on splitting
each activity into a different company
as a way to be more efficient and so in
2021 there was a new push in the
so-called spin-off operations or
segregation of line of activity in total
42 operations were announced with
combined value of about 20 billion
dollars
for example just three days before
general electric's announcement another
us giant did the same johnson and
johnson announced his intention to split
into two separate companies one focused
on consumer goods and the other focused
on drugs and healthcare equipment
shortly before this announcement ibm
carried out its own split by listening
kendra its technology infrastructure
services unit on the stock exchange for
its part united technologies separated
otis and carrier from its core business
and another ge competitor in this case
germany siemens also spun off its
healthcare and energy units amongst
others these are just a few examples on
an incredibly long list
[Applause]
[Music]
you see it is often thought that a
company always gains economies of scale
as it grows but this is not necessarily
the case as a company gains in size
especially if it engages in many
different activities it also generates
its own bureaucracy with all that this
entails in terms of costs and efficiency
and not only that it is also often the
case that by bringing together very
different activities strategic focus is
lost and decision making is diluted so
at the end no one ends up taking
responsibility it doesn't always happen
but these reasons are basically what is
driving this increasing specialization
be that as it may this is the story of
how general electric for decades the
most iconic company in the united states
floundered until it was no more than a
shadow of its former self in this case
it was the excessive gamble on the
financial businesses that finally pushed
it over the cliff and now if you found
this video interesting don't forget to
like it so we know and subscribe to all
of our videos here on visualpolitik to
keep up to date with everything we've
got coming in the future all the best
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you